beherrschende thema die erwartungen an
deutschland sind groß denn auch der brh
exit klimaschutz und digitalisierung
bleiben auf der agenda noch hat die
regierungserklärung nicht begonnen
obwohl die kanzlerin schon da ist im
plenum sobald sie redet schalten wir
natürlich ins plenum mein kollege frank
buchwald beobachtet heute die debatte
vor ort guten morgen frank noch streitet
die koalition ja über ihr programm für
die eu-ratspräsidentschaft es hakt so
ist zu hören bei den themen asyl und
kurzarbeit viele abgeordnete vor allem
der opposition fühlen sich übergangen da
es bisher keine schriftliche vorlage
gibt ein etwas holpriger start so
scheint es ja die kanzlerin hat ja immer
gesagt dass ihr diese rats
präsidentschaft sehr wichtig ist aber
sie hat sehr wenig darüber gesagt was
sie denn in dieser phase präsidentschaft
machen will und deswegen richten sich
natürlich alle hörten augen heute auf
angela merkel und auf diese
regierungserklärung im bundestag und
weil es ja keine generaldebatte gibt in
diesem jahr jedenfalls nicht jetzt wäre
ja normalerweise ein teil des
parlamentarischen kalenders deshalb wird
die opposition diese debatte heute
gewiss als eine art ersatz
generaldebatte nutzen und ganz generell
mit der politik der kanzlerin ins
gericht gehen
die erwartungen an deutschland an die
kanzlerin sind ja wirklich groß europa
hat sich nicht gerade von seiner besten
seite gezeigt am anfang der korona krise
kann deutschland diese erwartung
überhaupt erfüllen wenn die koalition
ist jetzt wirklich nur schwer schafft
sich auf ein gemeinsames programm zu
einigen
die aufgabe ist jedenfalls riesengroß
lange schon sind ja innerhalb der
europäischen union bruchlinien sichtbar
zwischen osteuropäischen und
westeuropäischen partnern nun kommt
durch corona bedingt und natürlich auch
noch verstärkt ein zusätzlicher konflikt
hinzu zwischen ländern im süden die
stark betroffen sind italien spanien und
anderen
im norden die weniger stark betroffen
sind von corona deutschland hat es ja
bisher ganz gut geschafft
also diese konfliktlinien oder diese
konflikte zu heilen zu überbrücken als
brückenbauer als ehrlicher makler
vielleicht das wird die große aufgabe
sein
einfach ist das nicht und da die
kanzlerin ja schon im vorfeld dadurch
dass sie ein rettungspaket beschlossen
hat dass anteile enthält die so etwas
wie gemeinsame haftung für schulden
enthalten
dadurch hat sie ja linien überschritten
deswegen wird es glaube ich für sie
schwierig werden zu überzeugen nicht nur
die opposition sondern auch in ihrer
eigenen fraktion wird sich da glaube ich
noch eine menge unterstützung werben was
ja keine leichte aufgabe wir schauen
jetzt mal kurz ins plenum
ich sehe noch hat die rede der
bundeskanzlerin nicht begonnen
wie gesagt sie ist zwar schon da wir
hören mal kurz rein
wir erwarten und jetzt sind ihnen der
fraktion l noch folgende änderungen der
tagesordnung vereinbart worden mit dem
tagesordnungspunkt 16 soll und
wahlvorschläge der spd fraktion für die
wahl jeweils eines mitglieds des
kuratoriums der stiftung denkmal für die
ermordeten juden europas und des
kuratoriums der stiftung deutsches
historisches museum aufgerufen werden
in verbunden aber gerade mit dem
zusatzpunkt 13 soll die zweite liberalen
des entwurfs eines gesetzes zur änderung
des bundes meldegesetzes auf der
drucksache 17 7 85 stattfinden
sie sind damit einverstanden dann ist
das so beschlossen der abgeordnete fan
brandner hat fristgerecht einspruch
eingelegt gegen eine in der letzten
sitzung erteilten ordnungsruf der
einspruch wurde als unterrichtung durch
den präsidenten verteilt gemäß § 39 der
geschäftsordnung ist der einspruch auf
die tagesordnung dieser sitzung zu
setzen
der bundestag hat über den einspruch
ohne aussprache zu entscheiden der
zeitpunkt der behandlung des einspruchs
würden später bekanntgegeben
jetzt rufe ich auf den
tagesordnungspunkt 10 abgabe einer
erklärung
jetzt gleich los und wir hören jetzt
rein in die regierungserklärung der
bundeskanzlerin
juni 2020 es liegen zwei
entschließungsanträge der fraktion der
fdp ein entschließungsantrag der
fraktionen die linke und einen
entschließungsantrag der fraktion
bündnis 90/die grünen vor für die
aussprache im anschluss an die
regierungserklärung wurde eine dauer von
60 minuten beschlossen und damit
beteiligt das wort zur abgabe einer
regierungserklärung der bundeskanzlerin
angela merkel ja sehr geehrter herr
präsident liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
meine damen und herren am ersten juli
beginnt die deutsche eu
ratspräsidentschaft das ist eine aufgabe
auf die ich mich sehr freue und auf die
sich die ganze bundesregierung sehr
erfreut denn europa braucht uns so wie
wir europa brauchen nicht nur als
historisches erbe das wir geschenkt
bekommen haben sondern als ein projekt
das uns in die zukunft führt europa ist
ja nicht einfach etwas das wir besitzen
es ist etwas das wir gestalten können
und müssen
europa ist eine offene eine dynamische
ordnung des friedens und der freiheit
die wir stetig verbessern können und
müssen europa lag am boden als es
geschaffen wurde zerstört zersplittert
und zerstritten nach der katastrophe des
vernichtungskrieges und des
zivilisationsbruch der shoa verursacht
durch die nationalsozialistische
gewaltherrschaft durch deutschland und
dennoch gelang es den gründungsvätern
und müttern das tiefe misstrauen
die bitteren erfahrungen aus krieg und
vertreibung nicht zu vergessen nicht zu
leugnen sondern anzunehmen und in ein
friedliches demokratisches europa zu
verwandeln
sie schufen damals mit dem unbedingten
willen zur versöhnung aus den trümmern
der feindlichen nationalstaaten eine
europäische gemeinschaft ausgehend von
einer wirtschaftsgemeinschaft
verpflichteten sich mitglieder
grenzkontrollen abzuschaffen und
freiheit und rechtsstaatlichkeit zu
verbürgen
das war die lehre aus dem furchtbaren
krieg das in europa nie wieder der
nationalistische rassistische waren
einzelne menschen oder gruppen
ausgrenzen und menschlichen dürfte das
in europa die politische kulturelle
religiöse vielfalt der menschen nicht
nur respektiert sondern beschützt werden
muss wir sind als europäische union
gewachsen
die europäische union hat sich nicht nur
erweitert sondern sie hat sich auch
vertieft europa ist nicht nur einfach
größer geworden sondern mit jedem gipfel
jeder verhandlung jeden konflikt jede
auseinandersetzung an substanz und ja
auch das wenn auch manchmal unendlich
mühsam an gegenseitigem verständnis
gewonnen das hat uns auch ermöglicht
viele krisen zu bestehen
die ablehnung der europäischen
verfassung vor der letzten deutschen
ratspräsidentschaft 2007 die finanzkrise
und die europäische staatsschuldenkrise
die uns ab 2008 erschüttert haben und
zuletzt 2015 die großen
flüchtlingsbewegungen das alles war
wahrlich nicht immer leicht da gab es
bittere konflikte und es gab auch
verletzung es gab auch immer wieder
missverständnisse oder fehleinschätzung
aber sie haben nie zum bruch nie zur
absage an europa geführt
daran so paradox es auch erscheinen mag
ändert auch ein einschnitt wieder
austritt großbritanniens aus der
europäischen union nichts nein mehr noch
auch diese entscheidung die wir uns
gewiss nicht gewünscht haben hat
letztlich nur dazu geführt dass uns 27
mitgliedstaaten der europäischen
nun sogar stärker denn je die gewissheit
leistet leitet es nur als gemeinschaft
schaffen zu können unsere europäischen
werte und interessen zu leben und
weltweit zu behaupten und das ist eine
ungeheure leistung aller in der
europäischen union
vielleicht meine damen und herren leidet
europa auch daran dass wir die wir
europa wollen
zu selten sagen worauf wir stolz sein
können vielleicht leitet europa auch
daran was wir es zu lange als
selbstverständlich genommen haben dass
wir es zu sehr den gegnern überlassen
haben über europa zu sprechen anstatt
dass wir die wir von europa überzeugt
sind es zum kern der politischen
diskussion machen und das behindert
behindert natürlich auch kritik oder
ungeduld die europa genauso braucht wie
fantasie und gemeinsinn und deswegen
lassen sie mich hier auch ganz
persönlich sagen als deutsche als jemand
die die ersten 35 lebensjahre in der ddr
gelebt hat erfüllt mich europa mit
seinen demokratischen versprechen von
freiheit und gleichheit unverändert mit
großer dankbarkeit
und mit der verpflichtung mich mit
ganzer kraft für dieses europäische
versprechen einzusetzen
denn europa wird nicht dass europa sein
dass wir wollen wenn wir jetzt passiv
und bequem hinnehmen europa wird nur
wachsen und gedeihen wenn wir unsere
ganze kraft darauf richten denn der
ehrgeiz dafür entwickeln was noch aus
europa noch werden kann und wir
übernehmen diese verantwortung in einer
zeit in der die europäische union der
größten herausforderung ihrer geschichte
gegenüber steht und deswegen ist für die
bundesregierung diese deutscher
ratspräsidentschaft mitten in der
pandemie eine so große herausforderung
denn wir müssen ja einerseits die folgen
der krise bewältigen aber zugleich auch
europa widerstandsfähiger und
zukunftsfähiger machen
die krise die wir gerade erleben ist
anders als all das was wir seit der
gründung europas erlebt haben die korona
virus pandemie trifft uns alle
unverschuldet und unvorbereitet in
deutschland in europa und in der ganzen
welt
sie hat allein in europa mehr als
100.000 menschen das leben gekostet
wenige wochen des wirtschaftlichen
stillstands haben ausgereicht um vieles
was wir über jahre aufgebaut haben zu
gefährden selbstverständliche
freiheitsrechte der bürgerinnen und
bürger wurden vorübergehend
eingeschränkt das war ein sehr hoher
preis und er ist jeden sehr an diesen
entscheidungen beteiligt war schwer
gefallen auch mehr
die kritischen stimmen zu den
einschränkungen der grundrechte waren
wichtig eine demokratische gesellschaft
in der sich niemand regt wenn
demokratische grundrechte angetastet
werden werden wäre
kein aber es gab und es gibt besondere
umstände unter denen ich diese maßnahmen
nicht nur für richtig sondern für
unverzichtbar gehalten habe und manche
wie die einhaltung des mindestabstands
von anderthalb metern oder einen mund
nasen schutz im öffentlichen raum weiter
für unverzichtbar halte denn liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen das virus ist
nicht weg es ist da solange es keinen
impfstoff und kein medikament gibt der
erleben ist ja auch jeden tag aber wir
müssen auch zugeben die pandemie hat
offengelegt wie fragil das europäische
projekt noch ist die ersten reflexe auch
unserer eigenen waren eher national und
nicht durchgehend europäisch das war so
gut manche gründe dafür auch gewesen
sein mögen vor allem unvernünftig denn
eine globale pandemie
wenn eine globale pandemie verlangt
gemeinsames internationales handeln und
wechselseitige unterstützung
ich bin froh dass die europäische
kommission unter ihrer präsidentin
ursula von der leyen so rasch und
umsichtig agiert hat und uns immer
wieder zu gemeinsamen absprachen
aufgefordert hat die pandemie hat uns
auch europas abhängigkeit von
drittstaaten bei der produktion von
medikamenten oder schutzausrüstung
deutlich gemacht defizite bei der
beschaffung bevorratung und verteilung
medizinische ausrüstung wurden
offengelegt und ja auch unterschiede der
wirtschafts und haushaltslage in den
eu-mitgliedsländern wurde durch die
wurden durch die pandemie verschärft
hinzu kommt dass die pandemie zwar alle
getroffen hat aber nicht alle gleich
die medizinischen und ökonomischen
folgen der krise vertiefen die
ungleichheiten in der europäischen
gemeinschaft die panne zeigt uns unser
europa ist verwundbar und deswegen sage
ich aus voller überzeugung
noch nie waren zusammenhalt und
solidarität in europa so wichtig wie
heute
kein land kann diese krise isoliert und
allein bestimmt sie lässt sich nur
überwinden wenn der miteinander und
füreinander handeln unser gemeinsames
ziel muss es jetzt sein die krise
gemeinschaftlich nachhaltig und mit
blick auf die zukunft zu bewältigen
und genau das wird das leitmotiv unserer
eu ratspräsidentschaft sein
ich bin überzeugt dass im angesicht der
akademie das engagement für die
europäische union nicht nur politisch
und menschlich geboten ist sondern der
leidenschaftliche einsatz für ein
solidarisches europa sich auch
wirtschaftlich als nachhaltiger erweisen
wird als alles andere
und natürlich braucht ein starkes europa
ein starkes deutschland dass dies so
bleibt dafür setzt sich die
bundesregierung mit ganzer kraft ein
indem wir die folgen der pandemie
entschlossen bekämpfen und dann ihnen im
schnellen und entschlossenen handeln des
deutschen bundestages haben wir
unterstützungspaket verabschieden können
die jetzt ja auch schon gewisse wirkung
zeigen und damit haben wir es nicht
bewenden lassen sondern ein kunstprodukt
konjunktur und zukunftspaket in höhe von
130 milliarden euro vorgelegt dass wir
ja in diesen tagen auch im parlament
beraten
doch zugleich sollten wir nicht
vergessen dass unsere nationalen
maßnahmen nur wirklich erfolgreich sein
werden wenn auch die anderen
mitgliedstaaten der eu stark sind und
wenn unsere nationales unser nationales
handeln durch europäisches handeln
flankiert wird es noch einmal ganz klar
zu sagen die pandemie und der mit ihr
verbundene wirtschaftseinbruch sind die
größte herausforderung in der geschichte
europas
die europa im vergleich zu anderen
regionen der welt diese krisen bewältigt
das wird über den wohlstand der
europäischen bürgerinnen und bürger
entscheiden und über europas rolle in
der welt aber die aufgabe ist sogar noch
größer
sie ist nämlich eine doppelte denn wir
leben ja in einer zeit in der sich ganz
unabhängig von der pandemie
so art zu leben und zu wirtschaften in
einem tiefen umbruch befindet getrieben
von zwei entwicklungen dem klimawandel
den wir mit einer kohlenstoffarmen und
in zukunft co2 neutralen lebensweise
begegnen müssen sowie der
digitalisierung die unsere art zu
arbeiten und zusammen zu leben
fundamental verändert und dass in einem
rasanten tempo und daraus folgt die
antwort auf die wirtschaftlichen und
sozialen folgen der pandemie darf eben
keine rückkehr zu herkömmlichen arbeiten
und wirtschaften sein sondern muss den
wandel in ein neues arbeiten und
wirtschaften stärken und beschleunigen
davon hängt ab ob er nach der pandemie
kreative wettbewerbsfähige unternehmen
und nachhaltig gesicherte arbeitsplätze
haben und wir wissen dass andere in der
welt nicht ruhen sondern sehr
entschlossen und sehr robust handel
in diesem geist aber ich mitte mai
gemeinsam mit dem französischen
staatspräsidenten emanuel makro 1 500
milliarden starken form für die
wirtschaftliche erholung europas
vorgeschlagen dieser soll den neuen eu
finanzrahmen in seinen ersten jahren
verstärken und vor allem die am
stärksten von der pandemie betroffene
regionen europas mit investitionen in
ihre zukunftsfähigkeit unterstützen
ich begrüße
ich begrüße sehr dass die europäische
kommission zusammen mit dem vorschlag
für die nächsten mittelfristigen
finanzrahmen ihren plan zur
wirtschaftlichen erholung vorgelegt hat
in dem sich auch zahlreiche aspekte der
deutsch französischen initiative
wiederfinden die aktuellen zahlen
belegen ja den dramatischen rückgang der
wirtschaftstätigkeit und
wirtschaftskraft in europa und deshalb
müssen wir jetzt entschlossen und rasch
handeln
daher werde ich mich dafür einsetzen
dass wir im europäischen rat möglichst
schnell zu einer einigung sowohl zu
mehrjährigen finanzrahmen als auch zum
aufruf kommen
die ausgangslage ist alles andere als
einfach aber ich hoffe darauf dass alle
mitgliedstaaten jetzt im geiste des
kompromisses handeln angesichts dieser
nie dagewesenen situation das beste wäre
wenn uns eine einigung vor der
sommerpause gelänge dann werden wir in
unserer rats präsidentschaft mit dem
europäischen parlament verhandeln und
die nationalen parlamente hätten zeit
für die ratifizierung des eigenmittel
beschlusses bis jahresende
dann könnten beide der mehrjährige
finanzrahmen und der plan zur erholung
europas die im übrigen zusammen gehören
zu beginn 2021 ihre wirkung zum wohle
europas entfalten
beim europäischen rat morgen der als
video konferenz stattfindet ist zunächst
nur ein erster austausch geplant und
danach wird es intensive konsultationen
durch den präsidenten des europäischen
rates geben
entscheidungen werden wir aber erst bei
einem physischen zusammenkommen des
europäischen rates treffen können der
plan zur erholung europas ist
ausdrücklich auf die pandemie bezogen
zielgerichtet und zeitlich begrenzt die
europäische kommission wird einmalig
ermächtigt anleihen im namen der
europäischen union am markt aufzunehmen
und diese für krisen bezogene zuschüsse
zu verwenden wir haben uns von anfang an
dafür eingesetzt
dass sie es auf einer sicheren
rechtlichen grundlage geschieht die
einstimmigkeit im rat erfordert und die
die haushaltsrechte der nationalen
parlamente achtet ich begrüße daher den
vorschlag der europäischen kommission
diese ausnahme maßnahme und ihre
begrenzung im eigenmittel beschluss zu
verankern
der dann von allen mitgliedstaaten
ratifiziert werden muss dieser form ist
ein dringendes gebot der stunde um eine
nachhaltige wirtschaftliche erholung
aller betroffenen regionen und bereiche
in europa möglich zu machen
nur so können der konvergenz
wettbewerbsfähigkeit und den
zusammenhalt in europa langfristig
sichern
wir dürfen nicht zulassen dass die
pandemie zu einem auseinanderdriften der
wirtschaftlichen perspektiven der eu
mitgliedstaaten führt und damit den
gemeinsamen binnenmarkt ein kernelement
europas schlecht und wir werden
entschlossen der gefahr entgegen
arbeiten dass sich dauerhaft ein tiefer
spalt durch europa zieht wir dürfen
nicht naiv sein
die anti demokratischen kräfte die
radikalen autoritären bewegung warten ja
nur auf ökonomische krisen um sie dann
politisch zu missbrauchen
sie warten
falls sich jemand angesprochen zu fühlen
sie warten darauf
sie warten nur darauf soziale ängste zu
schüren und unsicherheiten zu verbreiten
sich für eine nachhaltige entwicklung in
allen regionen europas einzusetzen ist
auch ein politisches instrument gegen
populisten und radikalen damen und
herren die erwartungen an die deutschen
eu ratspräsidentschaft sind hoch dessen
müssen wir uns bewusst sein
deshalb haben wir den der pandemie
unsere prioritäten präzisiert aber
gleichzeitig haben wir die anderen
großen herausforderungen unserer zeit
fest im blick
ich möchte an dieser stelle heute drei
bereichen erstens der klimaschutz und
mit ihnen der übergang zu einer
klimaneutralen wirtschaft weil der
klimawandel und auch der digitale
fortschritt unserer art zu wirtschaften
zu arbeiten und zu leben grundlegend und
tiefgreifend verändert haben wir
aufbauend auf den klimabeschlüssen vom
letzten jahr sowohl in unserem
nationalen zukunftspaket als auch beim
europäischen aufbau von klar auf die
förderung grünen wachstums und des
digitalen fortschritts gesetzt die von
der europäischen kommission vorgelegte
strategie für einen grünen deal bietet
gerade bei der erholung der europäischen
wirtschaft eine zentrale leitlinie und
auch eine große chance
vor allem für europäische unternehmen
mit hoher innovationskraft mit blick auf
die zukunftsfähigkeit europas und die
zukunft kommender generationen werden
wir auch die beratungen für ein
europäisches klimaschutzgesetz intensiv
fortführen mit dem ziel eine gemeinsame
position der mitgliedsstaaten zu
erreichen
unser ziel ist dass wir europas
klimaneutralität bis 2050 um das er ja
sehr gerungen haben rechtlich
verbindlich festschreiben können und
dementsprechend auch die ziele für 2030
anpassen
zweiter
wir wollen die digitalisierung von
wirtschaft und gesellschaft voranbringen
um den wirtschaftlichen erfolg europas
und damit seine handlungsfähigkeit auch
zukünftig zu sichern muss europa sowohl
technologisch als auch digital souverän
werden denn die pandemie hat überaus
deutlich gemacht in welchem
abhängigkeiten europas sich im digitalen
bereich befindet sowohl das technologie
aber auch was dienstleistungen betrifft
dabei bedeutet digitales souveränität
nicht dass wir in europa alles können
müssen wir müssen aber in der lage sein
selbst zu entscheiden wo europäische
unabhängigkeit geboten ist und wie wir
sie umsetzen wollen das gilt etwa für
den aufbau einer sicheren und
vertrauenswürdigen europäischen daten
infrastruktur
das gilt aber auch für den aufbau von
kapazitäten in kritischen technologien
wie etwa der künstlichen intelligenz
oder dem ganzen computing
hier wollen wir unsere eu
ratspräsidentschaft nutzen um weiter
voranzukommen
und drittens die weltweit dramatischen
folgen der pandemie fordern dass europa
mehr globale verantwortung übernimmt
und das in einer zeit in der das
politische klima nicht nur in europa
sondern auch weltweit rauer geworden ist
antidemokratische autoritäre menschen
verachte der anfechtungen sie nehmen zu
sie wollen das wofür europa angetreten
ist leugnen
sie wollen den rechtsstaat und die
gewaltenteilung ausgehöhlt sehen sie
wollen die würde des menschen an tasten
menschen und bürgerrechte in frage
stellen
sie wollen die auseinandersetzung mit
der geschichte die erinnerungskultur
beenden und nicht zuletzt wollen sie uns
das nehmen was wir zu jeder zeit
existenziell brauchen die unterscheidung
von wahrheit und lüge von
informationslecks 14 von wissen und
nichtwissen
[Musik]
den müssen wir uns entschieden
entgegenstellen nicht nur hier bei uns
nicht nur in europa europa und sein
versprechen von frieden freiheit und
gleichheit sind kostbar es kann uns
nicht gleichgültig lassen wenn es von
innen und außen beschädigt wird jeder
auch generation jede generation hat die
aufgabe ist neu zu gestalten
das ist keine historische bürde sondern
ein demokratisches geschenkt die welt
braucht somit gerade in dieser zeit
europas starke stimme für den schutz der
menschenwürde der demokratie und der
freiheit
denn auch viele humanitäre krisen
verschärfen sich aber treten vor den
aktuellen ereignissen scheinbar in den
hintergrund
wir werden daher in unserer eu
ratspräsidentschaft auch die bedürfnisse
anliegen und nöte unserer partner in den
der in der welt in den blick nehmen so
wird afrika ein aussenpolitischer
schwerpunkt der deutschen eu
ratspräsidentschaft sein
bereits jetzt zeichnet sich ab dass die
staaten afrikas besonders stark unter
den wirtschaftlichen und sozialen folgen
der korona virus epidemie leiden
zugleich haben gerade die staaten
afrikas viel erfahrung mit der
bekämpfung von pandemien wie die erfolge
woanders und anders oder gar dass bei
der bekämpfung des ebola-virus
eindrucksvoll zeigen auf dem gipfel der
europäischen union und der afrikanischen
union im oktober wird es daher darum
gehen gemeinsame antworten auf die krise
zu finden wie die folgen der pandemie
abgemeldeten können aber es wird auch
darum gehen afrika als kontinent der
zukunft in den blick zu nehmen und
unsere beziehungen partnerschaftlich zu
gestalten
auch europas beziehung zu china werden
weiterhin im mittelpunkt unserer eben
ratspräsidentschaft stehen die
entscheidung das für den 14
september in leipzig geplante eu china
treffen aufgrund der pandemie zu
verschieben ist uns nicht leicht
gefallen mit dem präsidenten des
europäischen rates shell und dem
chinesischen staatspräsidenten champion
bin ich mir einig dass wir dieses
treffen nach point
denn gerade gegenüber einem
strategischen partner wie china ist es
wichtig dass europa mit einer stimme
aller 27 mitgliedsstaaten spricht nur so
können wir überzeugen für unsere
europäischen werte und interessen
eintreten
ich plädiere für einen offenen dialog
bei denen wir mit china auch an so
wichtigen themen weiter arbeiten wie dem
abschluss eines investitionsabkommen es
fortschritte im klimaschutz oder unserer
gemeinsamen rolle in afrika aber genauso
bei fragen der rechtsstaatlichkeit und
der menschenrechte
und nicht zuletzt der zukunft hongkongs
wo ist die sorge umtreibt dass das so
wichtige prinzip ein land zwei systeme
mehr und mehr ausgehöhlt wird
diesen dialog werden wir auch in der
deutschen ratspräsidentschaft fortsetzen
setzen und hoffentlich auch als eu
ergebnisse für klimaschutz freihandel
und multilateralismus erzielen herr
präsident liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
das corona virus die korona virus
pandemie hat unser gesellschaftliches
wirtschaftliches und politisches leben
völlig auf den kopf gestellt wir leben
in der pandemie doch so die europa auch
die letzten krisen überwunden hat so bin
ich zuversichtlich dass wir auch diese
krise jetzt gemeinsam bestehen werden
nehmen wir uns frühzeitig fragen welche
lehren wir für europa aus ihr ziehen
können und was deutschland dazu
beitragen kann die von
kommissionspräsidentin von der leyen
vorgeschlagene zukunftskonferenz europas
könnte dafür ein geeignetes format sein
wenn wir uns in diesem rahmen auf wien
themen konzentrieren könnten wir in
absehbarer zeit zu konkreten und
greifbaren ergebnissen kommen unter
anderem dazu das schengen system
weiterzuentwickeln
das wettbewerbsrecht zu modernisieren um
es an die herausforderung von
digitalisierung und globalisierung
anzupassen
eine europaweite pandemievorsorge zu
entwickeln oder die schaffung eines
europäischen sicherheitsrats in
außenpolitischen fragen
all das ist von größter bedeutung doch
entscheidend und alles überragend wird
sein dass wir uns in europa mutig für
einander stark machen und gemeinsam neue
wege gehen gemeinde gemeinsam europa
wieder stark machen das genau ist das
motto der deutschen eu
ratspräsidentschaft dafür wird sich
deutschland dafür wird sich die
bundesregierung dafür werde ich mich mit
aller kraft und leidenschaft ins unserer
deutschen rats präsidentschaft einsetzen
und ich bitte sie lassen sie uns das
gemeinsam tun
ich bitte sie deshalb für diesen weg um
ihre unterstützung und ich bin überzeugt
das engagement für europa es wird sich
lohnen herzlichen das war die
regierungserklärung der bundeskanzlerin
ikone pandemie sei die größte
herausforderung in der geschichte der eu
zusammenarbeit jetzt wichtiger denn je
klar sei aber auch europa können nicht
zum herkömmlichen arbeit und wirtschaft
zurückkehren sondern müsse fit gemacht
werden und staat für die zukunft
traditionell antwortet die größte
oppositionspartei daher nun im anschluss
alles weide als nächste rednerin
fraktionschefin der afd
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident sehr
geehrte damen und herren
schade frau merkel wieder eine
gelegenheit verpasst um den bürgern
reinen wein einzuschenken reinen wein
über die enorme steigerung der
finanziellen lasten die auf unser land
zu kommen
da ist zum einen passend zum beginn der
deutschen ratspräsidentschaft die
dreiste forderung der eu-kommission die
deutschen eu beiträge um mehr als 40
prozent ansteigen zu lassen
das allein bedeutet rund 13 milliarden
euro mehr pro jahr statt den eu-haushalt
nach dem ausscheiden großbritanniens
entsprechend zu kürzen soll der deutsche
steuerzahler einspringen ja sogar
überkompensieren
zum zweiten das pandemie
anleiheaufkaufprogramm der ezb das erst
vor zwei wochen auf die astronomische
summe von 1350 milliarden aufgestockt
wurde
die korona krise muss auch hier als
vorwand für die quasi unbegrenzte
rechtswidrige staatsfinanzierung über
die notenpresse herhalten bürger der
letzten instanz ist der deutsche
steuerzahler der obendrein noch durch
die nullzinspolitik enteignet wird auch
dazu kein wort von ihnen und ich frage
mich haben sie eigentlich den warnschuss
aus karlsruhe nicht gehört wir haben das
und darum wird die afg fraktion auch
dagegen klagen dann drittens
der sogenannte green deal sie haben es
eben erwähnt kommissionspräsidentin von
der leyen jongliert mit mindestens einer
billion euro die sie für grüne co2
neutrale luftschlösser verpulvern will
wer soll das eigentlich noch bezahlen
viertens der sogenannte wiederaufbau
fonds in höhe von 750 milliarden euro
deutschland birgt allein für 135
milliarden mindestens wieder die inteco
ohne krise als vorwand um das tabu der
rechtswidrigen vergemeinschaftung der
staatsschulden zu brechen in paris
madrid und rom plant man schon eifrig
neue ausgabeprogramme die deutschen
bürger die jetzt schon länger arbeiten
höhere steuern zahlen und geringere
renten und privatvermögen haben als die
bürger der empfängerländer dieser
transfers müssen sich dagegen auch noch
höhere belastungen einstellen und all
diesen haftungsrisiken und
milliardentransfers haben sie zugestimmt
frau bundeskanzlerin obwohl wir in
diesem land genug eigene probleme zu
lösen haben für die wir unser geld
dringend brauchen wir sind kein reiches
land mehr die infrastruktur bröckelt das
bildungssystem stürzt ab in sachen
digitalisierung sind wir weit
abgeschlagen
die sozialen sicherungssysteme stecken
in der demographischen doppel falle aus
alternder bevölkerung und und
qualifizierte einwanderung in unseren
sozialstaat und dazu kommt der
volkswirtschaftliche schaden durch die
korona krise der von tag zu tag größer
wird wir haben heute bereits über sieben
millionen kurzarbeiter das sind zehnmal
mehr als auf dem gipfel der finanzkrise
im februar 2009 unserem land droht eine
nie dagewesene welle von
arbeitslosigkeit unternehmenspleiten der
mittelstand verarmt mit schulden
finanzierten ausgaben programmen kommen
wir aus dieser krise überhaupt nicht
raus nein ganz im gegenteil sie
verschärfen die krise dadurch noch mehr
und in dieser situation
haben wir auch keine milliarden zu
verschenken denn wir müssen uns selbst
helfen den lock down und die chor ohne
einschränkungen unter den
schutzbestimmungen vollständig beenden
damit der mittelstand wieder auf die
beine kommen zweitens steuern und
abgaben deutlich und dauerhaft senken
damit arbeitnehmer und selbstständige
wieder luft zum atmen haben
und drittens und vor allem nein zu neun
milliarden transfers und haftungsrisiken
mit dem deutsches volksvermögen für
euro-rettung und transfer union
verwendet wird handeln sie bitte im
interesse dieses landes und seiner
bürger frau bundeskanzlerin und
verstecken sie sich nicht länger hinter
ideologisch aufgeladener
phrasendrescherei wie sie es leider in
ihrer rede heute getan haben sehr schade
für diese verpasste chance
[Applaus]
die fdp-fraktionschefin mit harter
kritik an kanzlerin merkel im üblichen
ton der afd
nächster redner ist martin schulz von
der spd der ehemalige präsident des
eu-parlaments
vielen dank herr präsident sehr geehrte
kolleginnen und kollegen
wir sind durch harte wochen gegangen
mussten schwierige entscheidungen
treffen die nicht immer jedem gefallen
haben die aber notwendig waren und
weiterhin notwendig sind ich finde es
ist bewundernswert wie sich die menschen
in unserem land diszipliniert verhalten
haben und verhalten
besonders die die nicht anders konnten
die sich nicht verstecken konnten die
jeden tag zur arbeit gehen mussten die
mit ihrer arbeit uns allen geholfen
haben die den laden am laufen hielten
wir sind ihnen auch in dieser stunde
nach wie vor zu großem dank verpflichtet
aber meine damen und herren das war kein
deutsches phänomen
das war ja nicht nur bei uns so es waren
auch die menschen in italien die am
härtesten betroffen waren und immer mit
optimismus weitergemacht haben die
bilder singender menschen auf den
balkonen in rom haben uns allen das herz
bewegt und es waren die menschen in
spanien das land das am stärksten von
dieser pandemie betroffen war und bis
heute die höchsten infektionszahlen zwar
die menschen in frankreich die durch den
härtesten lockdown gehen mussten
selten haben die menschen in europa so
sehr im gleichen boot gesessen nein wir
sind nicht wie an nachrichten magazin
das am wochenende schrieb ein trauriger
kontinent im gegenteil
europa kämpft sich gemeinsam durch eine
globale pandemie deshalb ist das auch
ein europäischer moment und darauf dass
wir das in europa insgesamt bis hierhin
so gut
gemeistert haben darauf sollten wir
gemeinschaftlich stolz
es gab auch fehler grenzen wurden
geschlossen als grenzüberschreitende
hilfe notwendig gewesen wäre wenn die
nato unterstützung wurde zurückgehalten
da wo sie auch hätte gewährleistet
werden können und machen wir uns nichts
vor es entstand rund um die sogenannte
korona bond debatte der eindruck
deutschland seien nicht bereits zum
finanzieller solidarität das war absolut
falsch aber kommunikativ war es ein
desaster und die daraus resultierende
furcht vor dem auseinanderbrechen
europas hat bewegung erzeugt wir haben
ein erstes zeichen gesetzt mit dem
großen rettungspaket von 504 von 540
milliarden euro lassen sie mich an
dieser stelle sagen vermerkt ich habe
das gehört sie haben es erfunden
gemeinsam mit herrn markt der dank dafür
gilt aber insbesondere den
finanzminister der bundesrepublik
deutschland oder scholz die
binnengrenzen meine damen und herren
sind nun wieder auf vor allem für die
jungen menschen in europa die nie
grenzen gekannt haben und im gegensatz
zu manchen rechtsextremisten die gehofft
haben es gebe jetzt jubeln weil die
grenzen geschlossen sind gab es den
jubel als die grenzen wieder aufgemacht
wurden das ist das europa das die
menschen wollen und wir bringen ein
historisches wiederaufbauprogramm auf
den weg 750 milliarden wenn der
vorschlag der kommission umgesetzt wird
eine echte solidarische unterstützung
für die länder die am meisten in der
krise gelitten haben das ist ein
historischer schritt
in meinen augen eine längst notwendige
souveränitäts übertragung an die eu
ein schritt der zu einer echten
solidarität der tat führt das war der
begriff der gründerväter europas
solidarität der tat in der krise helfen
die starken den schwächeren
machen damit ein schritt hin zu einem
europa das schützt die rocky pro tisch
wie präsident marco das seit jahren
gefordert hat und ich finde frau
bundeskanzlerin dass vor allem nun sie
alles tun sollten um den vorschlag der
kommission mit der unterstützung der
bundesrepublik deutschland durchzusetzen
wir müssen diesen schwung nutzen in der
deutschen ratspräsidentschaft
denn sie haben es beschrieben frau
merkel alle alten probleme sind immer
noch da europa spricht nicht mit einer
stimme in der welt in der eu
respektieren mitgliedstaaten dieser
union die eigenen grundlegende werte der
union nicht und es tritt auch ein
mitgliedsstaat aus einige probleme sind
alt und sie müssen gelöst werden und wir
müssen die eu bauen zu einer echten
solidar union in der es eine
mindestbesteuerung für unternehmen gibt
in der sich die digital konzerne sich an
der steuer vorbei mogeln können in der
die klimapolitik beherzt angepackt wird
aber in soli darin solidarische und
sozialer verantwortung in der nicht die
überschüsse der einen die
arbeitslosigkeit der anderen sind einer
oper in der sozialen
mindestsicherungssysteme und einer
arbeitslosen rückversicherung eingeführt
wird ein europa in dem nicht die
selbstsucht der wohlhabenden die
verbitterung der ärmeren provoziert das
sage ich an die adresse der sogenannte
gallen 4 wie diese reichtums
separatisten fälschlicherweise genannt
werden
neben einer in einer solchen solidar
wissen sie mal wer sich schämen sollte
herr gauland der vorsitzende einer
partei deren position partei die sich
entschieden haben wir sie führt
demokraten oder neonazis der sollte sich
eben in einer solchen solidar union
leistet jeder den beitrag den er leisten
kann und wer diesen beitrag nicht
leisten will meine damen und herren sei
es in der flüchtlingspolitik oder in der
finanzpolitik
wer sich unsolidarisch zeigt wer die
grundlegenden prinzipien der
europäischen union mit füßen tritt der
kann dann auch nicht erwarten dass er
ohne sanktionen aus dem eu haushalt
finanziert wird
wir brauchen eine eu in der die
geschwindigkeit nicht von denen bestimmt
wird die eigentlich lieber rückwärts
gehen wollen es sind große
weichenstellungen nötig wenn sich die eu
um die großen fragen dieser zeit kümmern
soll dann braucht sie dazu auch die
notwendigen kompetenzen und ressourcen
wenn wir in der internationalen der
globalisierten welt klimaschutz handeln
soziale gerechtigkeit steuerpolitik den
frieden stabilisieren wollen dann
braucht die eu vertiefte strukturen dass
sie frau bundeskanzlerin eingestanden
haben dass diese debatte darüber bis hin
zu vertragsänderungen gehen muss kommt
etwas spät aber es ist der richtige weg
wenn meine damen und herren wir die eu
handlungsfähiger machen dann damit mir
nicht das erleben was wir im umgang mit
china erleben
die einen wollen richtigerweise
sanktionen wegen der polizeiknüppel in
hongkong
die anderen lassen sich von der
supermacht ihren hafen finanzieren aber
eine eu die nicht einig ist dieses
schwach dabei brauchen wir mehr denn je
und das ist der richtige teil ihrer
regierungserklärung und den richtigen
prinzipien für die ratspräsidentschaft
ein starkes europa der die stabilität
die die vereinigten staaten von amerika
über einen langen zeitraum der
weltordnung bei allen fehlern gegeben
haben sie bricht ja unter diesem
irrlichtern den präsidenten völlig weg
wir betreten wie die zeit es geschrieben
hat das post amerikanische zeitalter und
was die rolle europas in diesem
zeitalter ist
europa ist nicht nur ein staatenverbund
europa seine idee die idee von einem
gesellschaftsmodell in dem staaten über
grenzen hinweg kooperieren
auf der basis von werten die ihre
gemeinsame grundlage sind es sind die
werte von respekt toleranz vielfalt und
würde dieses modell ermöglicht uns seit
jahrzehnten das leben das wir lieben die
freiheit in der wir leben und den
wohlstand den wir genießen
dieses modell schützt niemand mehr für
uns wir müssen das selbst schützen
im wettbewerb der systeme zwischen den
unberechenbar gewordenen vereinigten
staaten einem expansiven china und dem
autoritären russland geht es für uns
europäerinnen und europäer für die
mitgliedstaaten der eu darum unser
moderne zu behaupten
es geht darum zu bestehen und mit
unserer idee einen positiven einfluss
auf die entwicklung der welt im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert zu nehmen
das momentum das durch die korona krise
auf entstanden ist bietet uns dazu eine
einzigartige gelegenheit unsere
ratspräsidentschaft ist deshalb eine
einzigartige chance für europa lassen
sie uns doch alle unsere kraft als
deutsche als starke mitgliedsnationen
innerhalb dieser staaten und völker
gemeinschaft nutzen um diese idee von
respekt würde toleranz und
vielfalt als gegenmodell gegen die
staaten die unwürdig intolerant
respektlos und voller verachtung
gegenüber allen anderen das 21
jahrhundert gestalten wollen das beste
das europa der welt zu geben hat ist
einigkeit die stark macht vielen dank
das war martin schultze nimmer als
leidenschaftlicher europäer er lobt die
eu die nach anfänglichen schwierigkeiten
jetzt die krise gut meistern würde als
solider union nach wie vor wird übrigens
auf abstand geachtet das plenum ist
nicht voll wie man sehen kann
die bundeskanzlerin hat ja erneut darauf
hingewiesen wie wichtig und abstand
halten und maske tragen ist nächster
redner christian lindner partei- und
fraktionschef der fdp herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen liebe kollegen frau dr
weide bei ihrer rede habe ich mich
gefragt welche anstrengungen sie
eigentlich unternehmen um gelegentlich
ihren eigenen politischen horizont zu
erweitern
gerade in diesen zeiten lehrt doch
eigentlich der blick nach china und in
die vereinigten staaten dass wir in
einem guten land leben und dass wir das
vereinte europa schätzen lernen sollten
zahlen dass die äußern darf sollte doch
maß voll sein
frau bundeskanzlerin sie haben
gesprochen
kurz vor beginn der deutschen
ratspräsidentschaft in einer wie sie
selbst unterstrichen haben besonders
herausfordernden millionen menschen die
in sorge sind um ihre wirtschaftliche
existenz und ihren arbeitsplatz als
folge der bekämpfung der pandemie als
folge des schutzes unserer aller
gesundheit mit dieser rats
präsidentschaft kommt nun auf
deutschland große verantwortung zu
dieser ratspräsidentschaft ist aber auch
eine große chance wenn man dereinst
zurückblickt auf diese zeit dann sollte
von ihr nicht in erinnerung bleiben dass
es eine ratspräsidentschaft der neuen
schulden gewesen sein
im rückblick soll man sagen es war
keiner rats präsidentschaft der neuen
schulden es war eine rats
präsidentschaft der neuen arbeitsplätze
und für dieses ziel frau bundeskanzlerin
wünschen wir ihnen erfolg und eine gute
hand
wir sind schwer betroffen durch corona
aber diese krise hat auch defizite
offengelegt dies bereits vorher gegeben
hat
und zwar nicht nur in europa sondern
auch bei uns hier ist oft von
wiederaufbau die rede
im wort wideraufbau klingt so etwas mit
als müsse es darum gehen den zustand von
vor corona wiederherzustellen
das kann nicht unser gemeinsamer ehrgeiz
sein die ambition muss größer sein
das ziel darf nicht sein das ist so wird
wie es vor corona war das ziel muss sein
dass es nach corona besser ist als
vorher
und wer endlich lange bekannte
strukturdefizite abgestellt haben
daran muss sich politik messen in europa
wie im inland
frau bundeskanzlerin sie haben diese
regierungserklärung genutzt um auch auf
die innenpolitik einzugehen und ihr
konjunkturpaket
deshalb erlaube ich mir dazu auch eine
bemerkung sie haben von den 130
milliarden euro gesprochen die
zusätzlich mobilisiert werden dimension
ist groß aber sicher angemessen
angesichts der herausforderungen jedoch
ist die frage zu stellen werden damit
tatsächlich bekannte struktur defizite
behoben
die frage ist doch zu stellen wenn die
130 milliarden euro neue schulden
aufnehmen und damit eine jüngere
generation belasten tragen denn diese
schulden dazu bei dass wir demnächst an
breiteren wachstumspfad haben der auch
bei der entschuldung hilft daran sind im
inland zweifel anzumelden in das
herzstück ihres konjunkturpakets und
herrn söder zu zitieren eine befristete
senkung der mehrwertsteuer ist besser
wäre es doch gewesen kleiner und
mittlerer einkommen dauerhaft steuerlich
zu entlasten ein struktur- defizit zu
beseitigen und deshalb auch die
zuversicht der menschen in der breiten
mitte des landes zu stark und auf
europäischer ebene
europäischer ebene sind diese zweifel
ebenfalls noch nicht entkräftet
wir wollen solidarisch sein in dieser
krise aber wer ist eigentlich mit wem
solidarisch belgien hat wenn ich richtig
erinnere die höchste zahl von corona
toten pro kopf belgien hat es einen
wirtschaftseinbruch von über zehn
prozent belgien gehört zu den staaten in
der europäischen union mit der höchsten
verschuldung und trotzdem wird belgien
mehr zahlen für die korona hilfen als es
selbst aus den maßnahmen erhalten wird
alle paradoxerweise hat die korona krise
keine auswirkung auf die korona hilfe
das ist auch keine überraschung dass das
so ist
nach den gegenwärtigen politischen
absichten wie in brüssel diskutiert
werden orientieren sich die korona hilfe
an makroökonomischen kennziffern der
jahre 2015 bis 2019 sprich es wird nicht
das land unterstützt wir sind nicht
solidarisch mit denjenigen die besonders
durch die pandemie betroffen sind
sondern mit dem die vorher bereits schon
wirtschaftliche probleme hatten
wäre man wäre man böswillig könnte man
sagen die hilfe geht nicht an die von
der pandemie betroffenen sondern ihnen
die am wenigsten wettbewerbsfähigen
volkswirtschaften mit den größten reform
defiziten und aus diesem grund frau
bundeskanzlerin fordern wir sie auf dass
sie wenn es darum geht diese programme
zu konkretisieren sehr konkret darauf
achten dass es konkrete diesmal konkrete
reformzusagen gibt das geld darf nicht
eingesetzt werden um strukturdefizite
erneut mit geld zuzuschütten sondern es
muss wirklich eingesetzt werden
das was schon lange bekannt war als
defizit endlich abgestellt wird und zwar
in interessen im interesse der menschen
die arbeit und ausbildung suchen über
über deutsche beiträge an den 500 oder
750 milliarden auch an unseren unseren
beiträgen für im haushalt der
europäischen union darüber darf man ja
sprechen aber und da sollen wir nicht
sofort sagen nein deutschland gibt
nichts und jeder erhöhung ist
ausgeschlossen aber gefragt werden muss
wofür wird das geld eingesetzt mich
wundert deshalb dass über 500 milliarden
gesprochen wird ohne dass man vorher
weiß wofür
zuerst ist doch die frage was brauchen
wir und danach was kostet es denn sonst
wird aus einer bazooka mit wumms nur
eine gießkanne die am ende nichts bringt
und wir werden sprechen müssen über die
frage wann und unter welchen umständen
zurückgezahlt worden martin schulz
sprach schon von eine mindeststeuer es
gibt unternehmen die wissen noch gar
nicht ob sie im nächsten jahr noch
existieren aber die spd will schon die
steuerlast erhöht manfred weber sagte
noch nicht bei einer gemeinsamen
veranstaltung ja wir bräuchten jetzt
eigene eu-steuern digital steuern oder
eine eu gewinn steuer bräuchte man davor
kann man nur warnen wenn die europäische
union liebe kolleginnen und kollegen der
csu mit ihrer unterstützung eigene
steuern erhebt dann wird es keine
politische kontrolle mehr über die
belastungs schraube geben deshalb muss
aus den mitgliedsstaaten aus dem
haushalt der europäischen union all das
an schulden getilgt werden was jetzt
aufgenommen wird nicht mit neuen steuern
und zuletzt kommt zum schluss
herr präsident frau merkel sie haben
gesprochen über weitere ziele wie das
klima auch das unterstützen wir nur was
sie konkret gesagt haben ist
ausschließlich die ziele zu verschärfen
wir haben keinen mangel an klimazielen
wir haben einen mangel an wirksamen
maßnahmen um sie zu erreichen
deshalb würde ich anregen dass sie sich
einsetzen frau bundeskanzlerin für das
ziel den eu emissionshandel auf weitere
sektion groß zu denen sie sprechen hier
in deutschland von internationalen
wasserstoff strategie über die man im
einzelnen sprechen kann das zum beispiel
die pkws ausgenommen werden ist ziemlich
paradox aber das wäre eine
innenpolitische debatte nur im zuge
ihrer ratspräsidentschaft sollten wir
uns doch an den gründungs impuls der
europäischen einigung erinnern
am anfang stand die europäische
gemeinschaft für kohle und stahl und
wenn es jetzt darum geht das europäische
einigungsprozess zu erneuern
dann sollte an seinem anfang die
europäische wasserstoff union stehen
damit der zukunftsenergie träger
zugleich der treibstoff für
wirtschaftliches wachstum
dann ging der fraktionschef der fdp
wünscht sich dass die deutschen
ratspräsidentschaft rückblickend als
ratspräsidentschaft der neuen
arbeitsplätze und nicht den neuen
schulden gesehen wird lindner fordert
konkrete reformschritte in den ländern
die gelder erhalten
es folgt nun reif trinkaus vorsitzender
der unionsfraktion
die kollegen spricht dass ich so kräuter
präsident dass wir jetzt die europäische
ratspräsidentschaft haben das was gar
nicht erwarten kann zu reden und in der
tat das ist für uns alle eine großartige
gelegenheit übrigens nicht nur für die
bundesregierung sondern auch für die
parlamente ich hätte gestern einer
dieser vorbereitungssitzung auf
parlamentarischer ebene zu dieser
ratspräsidentschaft und dann sagte ein
kollege aus dem europäischen parlament
ein netter kollege ja ihr nationalen
parlamentarier ihr seid ja wichtig sagt
ja die botschafter von dem was wir hier
in brüssel beschließen
da habe ich gesagt nee so ist das nicht
wir sind nicht die botschafter von dem
als nationales parlament war es in
brüssel beschlossen wird
wir sind bestandteil dieses
entscheidungsprozesses wie dieses europa
gestaltet wird und das nehmen wir uns
als parlament auch raus und deswegen
werden wir mitgestalten bei den
wichtigen fragen die jetzt zu klären
sind und das ist nicht nur die
überwindung der korona pandemie ist
nicht nur der mehrjährige finanzrahmen
das ist nicht nur der kampf gegen den
klimawandel sondern beispielsweise auch
ein gemeinsames konzept zur bewältigung
der migrationsfrage mal in armut herren
und und im übrigen von den übrigen ist
es auch ein schönes projekt für die
bundesländer und deswegen bin ich froh
dass zumindest ein ministerpräsident mal
heutigen hier auf der bundesratsbank
jetzt herzlich willkommen armin laschet
es wäre schön wenn auch angesichts der
europa-debatte die sehr wichtig sind für
dieses land der ein oder andere
ministerpräsident hier mal sitzen würde
ich sehe hier genau vertreter von zwei
ländern aber für bundesratsbank also da
könnte noch ein bisschen mehr gemacht
wären meine damen und herren
es ist insgesamt so wir haben große
fragen die wir zu klären haben überhaupt
keine frage
und wir werden noch viel über geld reden
müssen
und es ist auch gerade wieder viel über
geld geredet worden von herrn schulz von
herrn lindner von vielen vielen anderen
und das ist auch wichtig wir werden als
union darauf achten dass das geld
angemessen ausgegeben wird dass es
richtig ausgegeben wird wir werden
darauf achten wer zahlt wir werden aber
auch darauf achten wer zurückzahlt und
dass das ganze zurückgezahlt wird dann
ein europa der neuen generation wie
ursula von der leyen ausgerufen hat muss
auch ein europa der
generationengerechtigkeit sein und es
kann nicht sein dass konsumausgaben in
der gegenwart jetzt auf nachfolgende
generationen in diesem europa verlagert
werden meine damen und herren
aber es ist auch darüber gesprochen
worden mal wieder das europäische
institutionen gestärkt werden müssen
herr schulz das ist auch alles richtig
das ist überhaupt keine frage
aber glauben sie dass das der geist von
europa ist glauben sie dass das die
menschen von helsinki bis violette
motiviert an dieser europäischen idee an
diesem europäischen projekt zu arbeiten
wenn wir immer wieder über geld und
übermacht von institutionen sprechen
wenn wir darüber sprechen wer welchen
posten kriegt in diesem europa schauen
wir uns doch mal an wie die debatte in
den letzten jahren war sondern ich
glaube wir müssen diese rats
präsidentschaft nutzen frau
bundeskanzlerin eine renaissance der
europäischen idee wieder hervor zu rufen
uns wieder klar zu machen warum wir
dieses europa überhaupt wollen warum
dieses europa wichtig ist und das ist
mehr als ein binnenmarkt meine damen und
herren und und wenn wir uns damit
beschäftigen
und ich habe das mal versprochen dass
ich an dieser stelle dass bei jeder
europäischen rede sagen werde dann
müssen wir auch darüber reden dass
europa das größte und erfolgreichste
friedensprojekt dieser welt ist und jean
claude juncker soll einmal gesagt haben
all diese kosten die wir für dieses
europa haben und dann hören sie mal gut
zu all diese kosten die wir für dieses
europa haben ist billiger als eine
sekunde auseinandersetzung oder krieg
und das gehört auch zur wahrheit dazu
meine damen und herren das ist aber
schwer zu erklären wir leben hier in
kerneuropa seit 75 jahren in frieden wir
haben vergessen wie dünn das eis ist auf
dem wir stehen wir haben vergessen wie
schwierig das ist frieden auch unter
europäischen ländern zu halten und
deswegen müssen wir das auch immer
wieder klar machen und natürlich die
gemeinsame europäische idee das ist der
binnenmarkt das ist keine frage aber das
ist auch zu wenig ich glaube mal wir
müssen uns noch mit einer dritten
dimension beschäftigen das ist in ihrer
rede herr schulz ist es bei der
bundeskanzlerin angekommen und das ist
übrigens auch das große mantra vom
französischen präsidenten machen das ist
die europäische souveränität
meine damen und herren wenn wir hier als
parlamentarier weiter über das schicksal
dieses landes und dieses kontinentes
bestimmen wollen wenn wir selbstbestimmt
und selbstbewusst sein wollen dann
müssen wir uns einst gewahrt werden dass
die welt sich in den letzten jahren
verändert hat dass die welt sich in den
letzten jahren verändert hat und ich
glaube selbst wir deutsche als
viertgrößte volkswirtschaft auf dieser
welt sind zu klein um auf augenhöhe mit
china mit russland und von der einig den
vereinigten staaten zu spielen und wenn
das für uns als viertgrößte
volkswirtschaft gilt in niefern gilt das
denn für kleinere länder für portugal
für griechenland und auch für bulgarien
und rumänien und deswegen haben wir doch
nur eine chance
wir haben nur die chance wenn wir als
europäer gemeinsam agieren und allein
das ist dieses europa schon werte und
wir sehen doch welcher druck in der
vergangenheit ausgeübt worden ist da
heißt es wäre wenn ihr diese pipeline
baut da heißt es wehe wenn ihr unsere
menschenrechtssituation anspricht und da
heißt es wehe wenn ihr verhindert dass
jetzt irgendwelche unternehmen und
technologien aufgekauft werden können
und deswegen ist die frage der
europäischen souveränität die unsere
oder väter und mütter nicht im sinn
hatten die entscheidende frage auch für
diese europäische union und souveränität
heißt dass wir stark genug sind
gemeinsam als europäer auf unsere
interessen zu vertreten und deswegen
wäre es mir wichtig dass wir in dieser
ratspräsidentschaft auch darüber reden
wie wir eine gemeinsame europäische
außen- und sicherheitspolitik
organisieren können wir können als
deutsche nicht mehr allein im allgäu und
wenn wir über souveränität reden
da müssen wir auch mal über souveränität
über kritische infrastrukturen über
technologien reden ja sind wir denn in
der lage unsere mobilfunk und unsere
energien setze mit eigener technik
entsprechen noch auszubauen
sind wir denn in der lage unsere
schlüsseltechnologien im bereich
quantencomputer künstliche intelligenz
irgendwo auch unabhängig in europa zu
betreiben und dabei geht es nicht um
autarkie ich bin ein großer freund davon
dass wir eine arbeitsteilige
globalisierte welt haben aber es geht
darum dass wir nicht abhängig sind und
wie ist es mit den abhängigkeiten im
rohstoffbereich
ja wir haben es doch jetzt in der korona
krise gesehen dass bestimmte medikamente
oder grundstoffe für medikamente nur
noch aus bestimmten regionen dieser welt
kommen und auch das ist ein grund dafür
dieses europäische projekt entsprechend
zusammen weiter zu entwickeln es ist
eine frage der souveränität meine damen
und herren
und ich habe angefangen damit dass wir
uns als nationale parlamente auch auf
diese rats präsidentschaft freuen dass
wir mitmachen werden dass wir
mitgestalten werden und dass wir
natürlich auch mit entscheiden möchten
frau bundeskanzlerin und das verbindet
die ganze sache auch wieder zum anfang
nämlich zu der frage um zum ende der
souveränität ich glaube mal wenn wir
hier als parlament national souverän
sein sollen
und das gilt an die adresse des ein oder
anderen der nationale souveränität immer
ganz ganz nach vorne stellt dann können
wir das nur erhalten wenn wir europäisch
handeln wenn wir gemeinsam europäische
handeln und deswegen ist es wichtig dass
wir diese ratspräsidentschaft nicht nur
dafür nutzen war schwer genug ist die
korona pandemie zu überwinden sondern
dass wir diese ratspräsidentschaft dafür
nur
gemeinsam dieses europäische projekt
weiter zu entwickeln
es ist für uns eine überlebensfrage
vielen dank herr ralph brinkhaus fordert
neben allen großen aufgaben eine
renaissance der europäischen idee der
europäischen souveränität die eu sei das
größte friedensprojekt alle kosten für
europa seien billiger als eine
symbolische zitierte er jean claude
juncker nächste rednerin an ihrer
mohammed ali fraktionsvorsitzende der
linken sehr geehrte präsident
kolleginnen und kollegen
frau bundeskanzlerin europa braucht
hilfe die eigentlich großartige
europäische idee droht vollkommen
zerstört zu werden
aber genau das muss doch unbedingt
verhinderte
es steht schlecht um den zusammenhalt
und die solidarität in europa
das war aber schon vor der korona krise
so denken wir an die rigide sparpolitik
der eu in der finanzkrise in den
südeuropäischen ländern die griechenland
wurden gesundheitswesen wirtschaft und
viele soziale einrichtungen über jahre
kaputt gespart das hat viel menschliches
elend verursacht es hat die europäische
union entzweit die haben die regierenden
große fehler gemacht und wo war der
europäische zusammenhalt solidarität als
zehntausende vor krieg und elend flohen
in europa schutz suchten italien
griechenland wurden und werden bis heute
weitgehend allein gelassen und mit den
kindern frauen männern die jeden tag auf
dem mittelmeer ertrinken sterben auch
die europäischen wird das unerträglich
das ist man nationalisten kamen treiber
ihre politische macht errungen in
manchen ländern regieren sie sogar
sie stehen für ein europa in dem nicht
alle menschen gleichberechtigt und frei
sind
aber das muss doch weiterhin unser ziel
sein wir müssen alle aufstehen gegen
rassismus und diskriminierung in
deutschland und in europa auch das
bedeutet solidarität und zusammenhalt
als die bewohner krise europa trafen
italien besonders hart da hat die eu
italien im stich gelassen
hilfe kam zuerst aus kuba und china
bevor die europäischen nachbarn helfen
dass er tiefe wunden geschlagen
und wenn heute immer mehr menschen in
italien für einen eu austritt sind dann
müssen die regierenden das doch
verstehen und gegensteuern frau
bundeskanzlerin sie wollen darauf
hinwirken dass es gemeinsame europäische
pandemiepläne gibt und dass die
wirtschaftlichen folgen und die sozialen
folgen abgefedert werden das sind
richtige ziele aber sie wollen das
problem nicht an der wurzel anpacken
schon jetzt ist klar dass einige große
konzerne die amazon von der krise sogar
profitieren
aber zur kasse werden sie nicht gebeten
doch genau das müsste geschehen und zwar
sofort
auch in dieser krise in europa weiter
aufgerüstet anstatt ein europa des
friedens zu schaffen werden aber
milliarden für rüstung verpulvert das
unverantwortlich und nach ihren
konzepten werden am ende die kosten der
krise von den familien den
arbeitnehmerinnen den rentnern in paris
rom und berlin bezahlt werden die krise
wird zu last eine sozialsysteme gehen
aber das müsste nicht so sein
eine vermögensabgabe für millionäre und
multimillionäre
das wäre zb ein wichtiger schritt in die
richtige richtung aber darüber reden sie
nicht einmal im bundestag
und auch in nationales
konjunkturprogramm das hat eine
gewaltige soziale schieflage es bleibt
beim alten muster dass vor allem die
etwas bekommen die bereits viel haben es
müsste anders herum sein
auch jetzt ist schon absehbar dass die
gesundheitssysteme weiter kaputt gespart
werden vom privatisierungskurs soll
nicht abgerückt werden das fatal und die
korona krise
die trifft die ärmsten der gesellschaft
am härtesten das gilt für alle
europäischen länder ist gilt für die
ganze welt und nur ein beispiel sind ja
eben waren noch da heute da gewesen
es haben ja gestern gerade heraus dass
in einer deutschen fleischfabrik in
einem schlachthof bei tönnies in rheda
erneut in nordrhein-westfalen sich
wieder mindestens 600 menschen infiziert
haben überwiegend osteuropäische
arbeitskräfte schulen und kitas in der
region mussten geschlossen werden
tausende in quarantäne
die korona pandemie die bringt so manche
skrupellosigkeit ans tageslicht
wir brauchen hier endlich europaweit
verbindliche standards schluss damit
dass die arbeitnehmer freizügigkeit
missbraucht wird menschen als billige
arbeitskräfte auszubeuten und so soziale
und arbeitsrechtliche standards
auszuheben frau bundeskanzlerin
die haben jetzt die chance die richtigen
weichen zu stellen nutzen sie um die eu
zu einer gemeinschaft zu machen in der
nicht soziale spaltung aufrüstung und
abschottung ganz oben stehen sondern
solidarität nachhaltigkeit soziale
sicherheit und frieden für alle
die fraktionschefin der linken fordert
mehr solidarität in europa die eu habe
italien zu beginn der korona krise im
stich gelassen das habe dazu geführt
dass immer mehr in italien die eu
verlassen
merkel habe jetzt die chance die
richtigen weichen zu stellen
es folgt katrin göring eckardt
fraktionschefin von bündnis 90 grüne
herr präsident liebe kollegin gelegen
liebe frau bundeskanzlerin ich bin
thüringerin ich bin deutsche und vor
allem stolz europäerin die gar nicht so
wenige in europa bin ich in einer
diktatur geboren freiheit rechtsstaat
gerechtigkeit ich weiß wie ohne dass sie
anfühlt deswegen europa ist und bleibt
die beste idee die europa hier hatte und
doch deutschland und europa befinden
sich in einer doppelten krise die korona
krise und die klimakrise und diese
krisen meistern wir nur wenn wir beide
und wenn wir beide gemeinsam bekämpften
meine damen und herren und so
vergleichsweise gut wie wir in
deutschland durch die krise gekommen
sind während jedoch prädestiniert dafür
beim klimaschutz jetzt wirklich eine
führende rolle zu übernehmen und dazu
haben sie viele sätze gesagt auch schon
in ihrer rede zum petersburger dialog
haben sie gesagt dass deutschland sich
am klimaschutz sparen dürfe sondern
investitionen in zukunftsfähige
technologien benötige aber nur sätze zu
sagen das reicht eben nicht sondern es
braucht jetzt wirklich taten in brüssel
haben sie den nationalen klima planen
ein halbes jahr zu spät eingereicht
toilette und too late
das ist zu viel wenn wir sich wenn wir
uns das nationale programm anschauen
sie steigen mit 9 milliarden bei der
lufthansa ein mit flauschigen
absichtserklärungen zum klimaschutz
airbus hat das ziel ausgegeben bis zum
jahr 2030 emissionsfreies fliegen zu
übernehmen wo ist denn die initiative wo
ist denn ihre initiative die
europäischen airlines gemeinsam auf
linie zu bringen lufthansa voran
wo ist der plan für die schiene 130
milliarden euro und kaum etwas für die
verkehrswende und ihr konjunkturprogramm
von apple herr scholz sie haben gesagt
es ist ein paket
das schickt man in die welt und dann
hofft man dass der mensch sich freuen
wenn wir zu recht gesagt da ist nicht
alles falsch da ist viel richtiges drin
aber es sind eben kurzfristige
investitionen was wir glauben was es
braucht ist ein pakt das ist eine echte
verabredung mit den unternehmen in
deutschland mit den unternehmen in
europa mit den bürgerinnen dieses
kontinents dieses landes ein echter
packt der sagt wir verabreden uns für
langfristige investitionen für
zukunftsfähige investitionen für echte
nachhaltigkeit wir brauchen diese
planungssicherheit wenn wir die große
transformation wenn wir die große
umstellung schaffen wollen wenn wir es
schaffen wollen
aus dieser krise herauszukommen und
nicht altes zu restaurieren sondern
neues zu schaffen öko logisch und
gerecht präsident für die zukunft meine
damen und herren
und deswegen meine große bitte machen
sie diese ratspräsidentschaft zur klima
präsidentschaft das ist das ziel was es
braucht und ganz praktisch unterstützen
sie ein europäisches klimaschutzgesetz
das 65 emissionsminderungen bis 2030
verankert und jährliche co2 budgets
definiert investieren sie in den
recovery plan der den zusammenhalt und
eine klima feste wirtschaft schafft und
beenden sie die blockade einer
gemeinsamen agrarpolitik die klar auf
nachhaltige landwirtschaft setzen muss
die qualität und nicht fläche fördert
pestizide und überdüngung drastisch
reduziert und die sich ernsthaft um das
tier wohl kümmert man kann das an diesem
tag auch nicht weglassen meine damen und
herren das was in nordrhein westfalen
das was bei den tennis werken passiert
ist das ist nicht eingeschleppt das sind
die arbeitsbedingungen die wir hier
haben und das ist die art und weise wie
wir hier billiges fleisch produzieren
und deswegen meine aufforderung handeln
sie endlich das können sie nimmt die pi
kolleginnen und kollegen deutschland
kommt nur aus der krise wenn es unseren
nachbarn gut geht wir sind export land
und deswegen hat sich ihre initiative
gemeinsam mit manuela vor wirklich
erfreut
aber warum hat das jetzt genau drei
jahre und eine pandemie gedauert bis das
stattgefunden hat für die umsetzung
jedenfalls müssen sie einen gang
hochschalten merkel am ende
kanzlerinnen schafft tragen sie mit der
ratspräsidentschaft die verantwortung
für dieses land und für europa und es
ist an ihnen ob die milliarden in eine
krisenfeste eu und zukunft für unsere
kinder investiert werden so viel geld
dass gibt man nur einmal aus ich finde
geben wir es doch für das neue europa
aus was wird es was wird es gut für ein
europa seien am ende dieser rats
präsidentschaft ist es einst das geprägt
ist von solidarität von gerechtigkeit
von umwelt- und klimaschutz wollen wir
ein europa das für die rechte der
geflüchteten eintritt oder dulden wir
weiter die schrecklichen zustände in den
events lagern die moria die die
europäische idee jeden tag verraten wie
jedes einzelne jeder einzelne tote im
mittelmeer
es ist ein europa mit mehr nun gerecht
gerechtigkeit zwischen frauen und
männern
oder geht es weiter mit dem roll back es
ist ein europa der vielfalt in dem die
menschen sagen black lifes mörder oder
ist es ein europa in dem 100 polnische
gemeinden kreise und bezirke sich de
facto zur lgt iq freien zone erklärt
haben polen und ungarn bauen rechtsstaat
und freie presse systematisch ab und ihr
parteifreund herr orban leitet
alldieweil eu-mittel in seinem rolli
gleichen netzwerk um nein dafür darf es
kein europäisches geld eben meine damen
und herren
und wenn man sich das verständnis eines
europäischen vorgehens eines gemeinsam
gegenüber dem regelbrecher china
anschaut dann hat man schon das gefühl
da ist der prager bürgermeister manchmal
mutiger als der deutsche außenminister
wir müssen doch ein gemeinsames vorgehen
haben und herr brinkhaus sie haben davon
gesprochen ich habe ich habe fünf gehört
bei ihnen als sie darüber gesprochen
haben dass wir eine eigene initiative
brauchen ja bitte schön dann aber
gemeinsam und dann auch mit einer klaren
ansage an china und an die art und weise
wie dort gewirtschaftet wird und physik
wird
wir touren aufzukommen meine damen und
herren wir brauchen mit der
ratspräsidentschaft einen neuen
europäischen aufbruch europa krisenfest
machen mit solidarität als haltung mit
einem rechtsstaat programm und mit einem
echten green deal als innovations- und
wirtschaftsmotor das ist das neue europa
für das wir gemeinsam mit leidenschaft
kämpfen
die fraktionschefin der grünen fordert
dass deutschland jetzt beim klimaschutz
die führende rolle überleben soll als
ein wichtiges ziel hatte das ja auch die
kanzlerin in ihrer rede genannt doch für
die grünen fehlt ein pakt für
nachhaltigkeit fehlen konkrete vorgaben
und pläne
es folgt nächste hart baradar von der
spd sehr geehrter herr präsident sehr
geehrte abgeordnete liebe bürgerinnen
und bürger mit erlaubnis des präsidenten
zieht erich friedrich hölderlin da ist
und schwer zu fassen der gott wo aber
gefahr ist wächst das rettende auch die
auswirkungen der kroner pandemie haben
in europa tiefe spuren hinterlassen
laut european centre for disease
prevention and control haben sich
aktuell über 1,49 millionen menschen in
der europäischen union und in
großbritannien mit dem neuartigen corona
virus infiziert und rund 172.000
menschen haben ihr leben
die wirtschaftsleistung der eu ist
eingebrochen grenzen wurden geschlossen
und die direkten sozialen kontakte
massiv eingeschränkt die internationale
politik spielt verrückt wir standen und
stehen vor enormen herausforderungen
daher musste neue wirtschaftliche und
soziale wiederaufbau eines gesunden
europas unter dem vorsitz der deutschen
ratspräsidentschaft entschieden
vorangebracht werden
die vorschläge der deutsch französischen
initiative und die planung der eu
kommission sind der absolut richtige
ansatz dafür so entschlossen wie unser
nationales konjunktur und
innovationspaket muss auch in europa der
wiederaufbau aussehen stark und sozial
modern und gerecht
die zeitweisen ausfuhrbeschränkungen für
medizinische schutzausrüstung zu beginn
der ko unna pandemie sind ein mahnendes
beispiel dafür
wenn nationalstaaten allein und
unabgestimmt handelt dies sollte
dringend geändert werden
deshalb muss eine gemeinsame europäische
gesundheitspolitik zu den kernaufgaben
der eu gehören
der kommissionsvorschlag für ein
eigenständiges gesundheitsprogramm der
eu das programm bieten vorhält ist
außerordentlich richtungsweisend so
sollen nicht nur eine reserve von
schutzausrüstung und medikamenten
gebildet werden sondern auch bei
medizinischem fachpersonal enger
kooperiert und die schnelle
einsatzfähigkeit in der gesamten eu
ermöglicht werden
der gemeinsame austausch von
epidemiologischen daten soll dazu führen
damit schnell und angemessen reagiert
werden kann
die dafür vorgesehenen mittel in höhe
von 9,4 milliarden euro stellen die
absolute untergrenze dar und dürfen in
den kommenden beratungen nicht gemindert
werden
mit diesem programm besteht die
möglichkeit dass zukünftig dringend
notwendige güter nach medizinischer
ich kann es leider nicht mehr da und
nicht nach finanzieller kraft in europa
verteilt werden
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen diese
verteilung gilt ebenfalls entschuldigung
da haben sie hoffentlich zugehört liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
diese verteilung gilt ebenfalls für den
hoffentlich bald zur verfügung stehenden
impfstoff gegen code 19
die internationale geberkonferenz der eu
zur anschubfinanzierung der impfstoff
suche anfang mai war mit einem ergebnis
von 7,4 milliarden euro
ein voller erfolg die europäische
investitionsbank stellte einem deutschen
pharmaunternehmen in der vergangenen
woche ein kredit bis zu 100 millionen
euro zur produktion für den impfstoff
zur verfügung auch dies ist ebenfalls
ein ermutigendes europäisches zeiten
wir wollen wir wollen einen impfstoff
für die ganze welt für uns gilt nicht
europe first für uns gilt humanity first
die anfang der woche vorgestellte
deutsche corona vanek ist
fortschrittlich und wird uns helfen
infektionsketten besser nachverfolgen zu
können
in einem nächsten schritt brauchen wir
eine gesamteuropäische anwendung über
landesgrenzen hinweg das ergebnis wäre
ein deutlich detaillierteres lagebild
des pandemie geschehen in ganz europa
und die europäische union hat die kraft
und die möglichkeit dazu lassen sie uns
jetzt die ärmel krempeln wir haben viel
vor uns vielen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
die spd-abgeordnete baradar ihr lob dem
deutsch-französischen vorschlag für den
eu wiederaufbau fordert wie viele redner
zuvor auch ein solidarisches europa es
folgt nun harald meyer
[Applaus]
hertha-präsident kollegen und zuschauer
die kanzlerin optimiert hiermit quasi
veruntreut um steuergeld die steigerung
der eu fiskal ausbeutung inländischer
sparer und steuerzahler am ende stehen
reformverweigerung erlernte
hilflosigkeit und immer dreistere
forderungs gebaren der wohltat
adressaten mit der fremdfinanzierung
nationaler sozialpolitik in dem
unsäglichen sure vorhaben dem ominösen
recovery fand oder von der leyens 750
milliarden pseudo programm runden sie
die ganze schlecht europäische anti
subsidiaritätsrüge räder not wird sich
nach rein französischen autor und seinen
nutzen die st eingerichtet mit
systemwidrigen nicht leistungsanreizen
für andere leute regierungen
staatshaushalt und wirtschaft wird
hierbei selbst der keynesianismus ad
absurdum geführt großteils verschenktes
geld für andere staaten als kaufprämie
für rendite lose konsum investitionen
wofür
und das während hierzulande nicht nur
die infrastruktur verrottet ich
gratuliere mit panik und hysterie
strategie haben sie das land
nacheinander getrieben von euro-politik
waren der die finanzen ruiniert in den
klimapolitik waren der die umwelt
schädigt in den corona politik waren der
auf die wirtschaft wirkt wie eine
neutronenbombe und kein neuer spuk hat
die den alten aufgelöst wie manche
hoffen
nein
apokalyptischen reiter sitzen uns
zugleich im nacken und der führte ist
ausland eingetroffen
eine völlig überkandidelte
antidiskriminierungspolitik die die
bevölkerungsmehrheit diskriminiert und
polizei und justiz genauso durch das
funktionalisiert wie es beim militär
schon gelungen ist dabei geht
nachbarschaftshilfe auch ganz
international über sachleistungen und
dergleichen corona ist genau nicht das
erdbeben von haiti als dass es verkauft
wird und das letzte sinnvolle
krisen-management brüssels liegt 50
jahre zurück die strategische ölreserve
die ganz unspektakulär genau 90 tage öl
und treibstoff bedarf abdeckt und
punktgenau das und nur das kann man auch
ganz unspektakulär für medizingeräte und
arznei bedarf et cetera machen aber
beispielsweise der bei geräte bedarf an
atemgeräten hat sich inzwischen offenbar
in luft aufgelöst
und oft genug auch noch als tödliche
fehlbehandlung herausgestellt et cetera
pp die heiss gestritten monetären hilfs
not und krisen programme dürften sich
als betrügerische haustürgeschäfte
erweisen fällig wäre vielmehr eine
nachhaltige ganzheitliche allumfassende
deutsche nichtzuständigkeit erklärung
für derlei fremdbestimmte anlegen just
say no und ein letztes wort hat
brinkhaus sie hatten so schön diese
friedensdividende erwähnt und soweit ich
darf darauf aufmerksam machen
der wunderbare finanz historiker oxford
und so weiter neil ferguson hat 2011
festgestellt dass die damaligen finanz
rettungsübungen einer eu schon die
kosten eines weltkriegs beinhaltet
hatten und das war 2011 deswegen hat
völlig zu recht die eu deswegen hat
völlig zu recht die eu auch 2012 den
friedensnobelpreis
weil sie bewiesen hat dem tiefsten
frieden einen schaden anrichten kann
auch weltkriegs war
ich danke das war der afg abgeordnete
weil der die monetären hilfsprogramme
heftig kritisiert wie auch schon sein
die fraktionschefin der afd beide zuvor
nächster redner ist nun alexander
dobrindt der chef der csu landesgruppe
im bundestag serie präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen meine damen und
herren wir brauchen europa als
wachstumsgarant und deswegen lieber herr
weil ich kann überhaupt nicht
nachvollziehen was sie versuchen hier
darzustellen was die politik
deutschlands gegenüber europa beinhaltet
also jetzt in dieser phase darüber zu
reden dass es eine anti subsidiarität
orgie von veruntreuung von steuergeldern
zu reden oder das ist ja alles in der
tradition auf was man in den letzten
tagen gehört habe ihr kollege gottschalk
der spricht von der deutschland als
melkkuh europas ich kann ihnen nur sagen
es macht einen entscheidenden
unterschied ob der nachbar in
schwierigkeiten geraten ist weil er
seine lohntüte verzockt hat oder weil er
durch eine katastrophe betroffen ist
hier nicht selbst zu verschulden hat und
genau dieser unterschied macht es dann
auch aus ob wir solidarisch sind oder ob
eher skeptisch unserem nachbar gegenüber
eintreten und deswegen kann ich ihnen
nur sagen wir stehen auf der seite der
solidarität es macht für uns eben einen
unterschied und ich will ihnen an der
stelle sagen wer in dieser phase in
dieser entscheidenden phase europas
davon spricht dass deutschland die
melkkuh ist weil wir uns finanziell
engagieren
der muss aufpassen dass er nicht zum
rind viel diesem parlament wird meine
damen
wir brauchen wir brauchen ein europa im
aufschwung
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wenn
europa im abschwung ist kann deutschland
nicht in einen aufschwung kommen und
deswegen ist es umso bedeutender dass
wir jetzt in unserer ratspräsidentschaft
nicht nur ein paket zur bewältigung der
krise spüren sondern dass wir vor allem
auch eine agenda für den aufbruch
schnüren und zu dieser agenda für den
aufbruch da gehört es natürlich dazu
dass wir über ein souveränes deutschland
und hatte war souveränes europa reden
dass wir über innovation in deutschland
und in europa reden dass wir die
widerstandsfähigkeit europas stärken
oder wie es die bundeskanzlerin dass wir
an einem starken europa bauen das ist
uns übrigens schon mal gelungen in
unserer letzten ratspräsidentschaft 2007
ich darf mal daran erinnern damals war
europa auch in einer politischen krise
der europäischen verfassungsvertrag war
gescheitert weil in referenten die
bevölkerung in abgelehnt haben und
damals haben wir mit der berliner
erklärung den weg aus der krise gewesen
heute steht europa noch vor größeren
herausforderungen und unsere rats
präsidentschaft ja die muss die agenda
des aufbruchs bringen mit souveränität
mit wachstum ja natürlich auch mit
ökologischem wachstum auch das gehört
dazu und wir müssen den willen haben als
europa ein aktiver spieler auf der
weltbühne zu sein und nicht der
spielball zwischen den machtzentren und
deswegen gehört ja ein aktiver
welthandel
natürlich dazu ja es gehört wettbewerb
und partnerschaft gleichermaßen dazu
es gehört dazu den austausch auch
international auch wirtschaftlich zu
aktivieren und zu pflegen aber es gehört
nicht dazu einseitige abhängigkeiten zu
bestimmten regionen der welt zu
akzeptieren und deswegen ist es auch ein
besonderes wichtiges signal dieser
koalition dass wir die souveränität auch
in unserem paket zur krisenbewältigung
stark formuliert haben sowohl was die
versorgung von medikamenten anbelangt
mit die versorgung mit medizinischen
produkten da deutschland und europa zu
stärken die produktion wieder mehr zu
beheimaten
auch das ist eine aufgabe und ich bin
dem besonders in dem
bundesgesundheitsminister jens spahn
auch sehr dankbar dass er mit der
allianz gemeinsam mit frankreich italien
und den niederlanden dafür gesorgt hat
dass wir zugriff zukünftig auch auf
zirka 300 millionen impfdosen haben wenn
sie dann wirkungsvoll zur verfügung
gestellt werden auch das ist ein
wichtiger beitrag für eine europäische
souveränitäts offensive meine damen und
herren
natürlich gibt es da auch um sicherheit
da geht es auch um schlüsseltechnologien
da geht es um künstliche intelligenz da
geht zum quantencomputer da geht es
darum dass wir europa in europa auf
eigenen beinen stehen können und es geht
darum dass wir die abhängigkeiten
reduzieren deswegen vor bundeskanzlerin
unsere dringende bitte das thema
souveränität auch zu einem schwerpunkt
unserer rats präsidentschaft zu machen
meine damen und herren das geld um das
es geht und das angesprochen worden ist
ja das muss in die modernisierung der
europäischen staaten fließen und es darf
nicht zur verlängerung von maroden
haushalten führen das ist ein teil auch
unseres
projekts und weber martin schult sich
darf sie ansprechen an der stelle weil
sie in ihrer rede despektierlich über
die sogenannten sparsamen 4 gesprochen
haben ich habe aber kein zweifel an der
ihrer europäischen kompetenz und ihrer
langen erfahrung auch in brüssel und in
europa aber ich glaube dass man sehr mit
vorsicht damit umgehen müssen dich mit
umgehen muss nicht alles was da
vorgeschlagen wird von diesen vieren hat
auch unsere zustimmung auch gar nicht
meine zustimmung aber dass man
diejenigen die sich für solide finanzen
in europa versuchen einzusetzen dass man
die pauschal als reichtum separatisten
diffamiert das ist der falsche weg weil
es genau denen in die hände spielt
wieder dauer schulden wollen oder raus
aus europa rollen das ist nicht unser
ziel
meine damen und herren ein punkt an der
stelle weil auch der gehört dazu wir
haben ein urteil des verfassungsgerichts
in den vergangenen wochen erlebt zum
handeln der ezb auch das spielt eine
große rolle bei den weiteren beratungen
und muss eine große rolle bei weiteren
beratungen nicht nur in deutschland
sondern auch in brüssel spielen
das verfassungsgericht hat sich
auseinandergesetzt
nicht nur mit den finanzen sondern auch
mit der zentralen frage des
verhältnisses der mitgliedstaaten
gegenüber auch der europäischen union
und meine bitte frau bundeskanzlerin
auch das muss angesprochen werden die
reaktion brüssels die reaktion der
europäischen union und der institutionen
auf ein gerichtsurteil des
bundesverfassungsgerichts ich fordere
da mehr sensibilität ein überheblichkeit
der europäischen institutionen mit einem
deutschen verfassungsgerichts urteil das
ist nicht akzeptabel und wenn ein
ezb-ratsmitglied sagt das urteil sei
lächerlich und die kommission
möglicherweise mit einem
vertragsverletzungsverfahren droht dann
kann man nur sagen ein europa der
akzeptanz braucht argumente und weniger
arroganz herzlichen dank das waren
gewohnt deutliche worte des csu
landesgruppenchefs dokument wir blenden
uns hieraus ich bedanke mich für ihr
interesse so wie es aussieht werden es
sehr spannende wichtige sechs monate
werden für deutschland und die eu hier
im programm geht es jetzt weiter mit
notruf hafenkante
ich sage tschüss und freue mich wenn sie
beim nächsten mal wieder mit dabei sind
[Musik]
ihr könnt die beiden jugendlichen laufen
lassen wir haben die täter gefunden